hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we are talking about how to
survive
the job hunt yeah yeah we are so close
to 1 000 subscribers
thank you so so much to all of you part
of this community
i i i appreciate you so much so i want
to do something for
y'all i want to do a little giveaway if
you see this sweatshirt
i'm wearing it says the black female
engineer if you go follow me on
instagram
and also comment on my videos between
now and the point i'm at 1 000
subscribers you will be in the running
to get
this hoodie i'll select three people in
total
i provide more details in the
description box below so check those out
but anyway let's get to it number one
have a
goal for your application process have a
goal of
how many applications you want to submit
in a day
in a week that way you always feel some
sense of accomplishment
because it's so easy to feel defeated
while job hunting
that you need something to be like yes
okay i did that
and that actually brings us perfectly to
number two whatever that goal is
try to complete it early in the early
half of the day
because in the you know
process of just constantly feeling
defeated you want to you don't want to
end your
day like that you don't want to go to
bed
feeling distraught feeling anxious
feeling x y and z
so do that at the beginning of your day
as as much
as close to the beginning of the day as
possible and then
that way you can go about your life and
go to bed thinking about whatever the
last thing you did
was now it's no secret that job hunting
can take
a hot minute a hot a hot scorching
minute
so here's number three every one month
at
least every one month but i wouldn't say
no more than like once every two weeks
find something to revamp and i mean
every one month of seeing just
no movement seeing no calls for
interviews seeing no
y and z try to see what you can revamp
what
can you do to your resume what can you
do to your linkedin what can you do to
your github
to just make it better make it just feel
fresher because then
also after that you'll enter the new
month of job
hunting and applications with a new
sense of hope
because there may be something in there
that's you know turning people away for
some reason and honestly it doesn't take
much
these days but there might be something
in there and you want to just keep on
adding that edge to your applications
number four i really wish i had done
this
mute email notifications for
some part of your day y'all oh my gosh
it it's not fun um going through your
day
having a great day you just went i don't
know fishing with your dad
he just caught a big fish came back had
a great dinner
and then boom you get two rejections for
the job you really wanted
mute email notifications for some point
in the day
now not for all the entire days and
weeks because
a lot of times when you get either
interview invites or
advice to complete coding questions
those offers expire within 24 to 48
hours so don't do this like the entire
day and blame me for anything
but just make sure that you say you know
what
for the last six hours of my day i make
sure that email notifications are off
or even sync it with your working
schedule if you are working right now
saying only nine to five email
notifications would be on other than
that then like boom
you can't reach me it feels a lot better
knowing that
during these times i'm more prepared to
hear bad
news number five track your applications
track your applications because you may
think like oh i don't need to track them
i don't
want i don't want to see all the jobs
that i'm not getting invites and
interviews to
and two you may think that's just like
why it's out there so why do i need
tracking
you want to track your applications
because one it gives you a
sense of when you'll hear back from
companies typically
in my experience i would always hear
back between two to
like five-ish weeks after applying and
so if week six came by
and you know google has not responded to
me
then i can kind of plan my next steps do
i know the email of the recruiter do i
know
you know do i have a contact card from
anybody
or even from their website can i reach
out and be like hey
i just was inquiring about the status of
my application and just getting some
kind of
update because knowing is better than
not knowing for me unless you move on
lets you figure out you know how to best
proceed
and so track your applications i
actually have a job tracker
which i have linked below it's free to
use for you to download just copy the
instructions below
but yeah just something simple to know
when things were sent out to know which
companies you have interviews to
and also what your next step is in terms
of okay you just had an interview for
these
two companies make sure you send them
thank you notes make sure you do x y and
z
and all of that and let me just add a
note here
it's also important to track because
the i have heard stories this never
happened to me but i've heard stories of
my friends saying that
if i hadn't gone back to this company
saying hey
i applied x amount of weeks ago and i
just wanted to receive an update
they wouldn't have gotten their
interview because either the resume
didn't go through correctly
or they just forgot about them like you
know
we're all people so they just forgot
even though their resume stood out and
things like that and even just showing
that you're interested even showing that
you're keeping an
eye on you know your notifications and
you care
it ended up giving them interviews
and so that's also why it's important to
track your application
and finally it's so easy to just be like
no i need a job now this was me i was
like i need a job yesterday i need
to just keep going keep hustling keep
sending these out
yo have a resting day
have a resting day because it will keep
you
just in lighter spirits you know
because if you're just so run down from
the 45
days of continuous application sending
by the time you even get that interview
it's like you know what screw it i don't
even want it anymore like you
want to make sure you're keeping your
spirits up as much as possible
and if you just have one resting day
just at least once
some type of sacred day to you it'll
help you
so much more in the long run but please
know i give none of these tips lightly
i know the time i spent applying to jobs
oh my gosh the anxiety levels i was not
sleeping i was just
running all of these scenarios in my
head constantly especially when you fell
in love
with a job or a job description and
they're like nah son that
it's not fun so please no i'm not giving
these lightly and i just
am reflecting back on my experience and
really
some of these things i wish i had done
some of the things i did do and i'm so
glad i did and so just
i hope you take that and it helps you
out even just
leave it just a little bit so thank you
so much
and i'll see y'all later bye